I think college is meant to be a time
when you decide who you are and what
you're gonna do with the person that you
are trying to understand true bonds
people together in a way in which very
few other things do I knew I wanted to
go to a college that would be
spiritually edifying a place that would
be not safe for my faith but a safe
place to grow there's always this
collaboration of students just getting
together supporting one another wanting
to be the best that we can be the
liberal arts are not as much about
gathering information as they are
learning to be a right kind of person to
land on your feet the core curriculum
has been essential to really see the
world as a complete picture the
professor's don't see the students as
bodies in the desks they really see
minds to train and souls to cultivate
College is meant to be a place where we
are prepared the rest of our lives where
we are formed and we are shaped in order
to act as good human beings with an idea
of the true and the good of the
beautiful
you